[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه هو من
جميع جوانبه نبدا بالعرب
بعد تصعيد اسرائيل بغزه نتنياهو يتوعد برد
ساحق على اي تهديد لامن اسرائيل وترقب لرد
الفصائل
بعد اعتقالي عمران خان اعمال شغب بباكستان
واقتحام لمقر عسكريه واستخباراتيه
مؤسس فاغناري يهاجم مجددا قاده روسيا
العسكريين ويتحدث عن فرار قوات روسيه من
باخمت
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
على شركات صينيه بسبب تعاملها مع روسيا
نبدا نشرتنا من التصعيد الاسرائيلي في غزه
فبعد غارات عنيفه شنها الطيران الاسرائيلي
على القطاع وادت لمقتل ثلاثه من القاده
العسكريين لحركه الجهاد الاسلاميه ومدنيين
بينهم نساء واطفال توعدت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه بالرد فيما تعهد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو برد ساحق على
اي تهديد لامن اسرائيل
ربما على اكثر من جبهه يجب ان نوضح
لاعدائنا ان اي تصعيد من جانبهم سيقابل
برد ساحق اتفهم الرغبه في استهداف هؤلاء
فورا لكن علينا التمهل في استخدام القوه
كتحذير اخير نتصرف دائما ضد اولئك الذين
يسعون الى القضاء علينا ولكن في وقت مناسب
لنا
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيليه قال بدوره ان
العمليه العسكريه في غزه اثبتت قوه
المنظومه الامنيه وكاد ان اسرائيل مصممه
على احباط اي تهديد وجاهزه لاي سيناري
وبما فيه معركه طويله الامد
فور اطلاق الصواريخ على اسرائيل قبل نحو
اسبوع استعد الجهاز الامني للتعامل مع
قاده الجهاد في غزه وقمنا باستهدافهم خلال
عمليه سريعه وخاطفه من جربنا فهم قوه
اسرائيل وقوه النظام الامني نحن مصممون
على احباط اي تهديد والعمل ضد اولئك الذين
يحاولون الحاق الاذى بنا
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اعلنت السلطه الفلسطينيه ارتفاع
عدد قتل الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه
الى 15 قتيلا بعد مقتل الفلسطينيين اثنين
في غاره جديده استهدفت سياره جنوب قطاع
غزه وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف
خليه كانت تنوي اطلاق صاروخ مضاد للدروع
وينضم الينا من الناصره المحلل السياسي
نظير مجال اهلا بك معنا السيد نظير في هذه
النشره بدايه كيف تفسر التاخير بالرد من
قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه لانه بالمقابل
استمعنا منذ قليل لمؤتمر صحفي لنتنياهو
وايضا لوزير الدفاع
تحدثا خلالها عن يعني تهديدات وقوه الرد
الاسرائيلي بالمقابل
مساء الخير لكي استاذه راويه بالاخوه
المشاهدين والمشاهدات واضح ان التاخير
اولا لانه بالنهار صعب ان يطلقوا صواريخ
والدليل ان السياره التي حاولت ان تستعد
او تتموقع في منطقه معينه لكي تضرب دبابات
الاسرائيليه تم قصفها وتدميرها وقتل من
فيها ولذلك يعني ينتظرون الليل مثلا الليل
هو الذي سيقرر اذا كان الجهاد الاسلامي
معنيا بالتوسيع وبالتصعيد وباستمرار الرد
ام لا وطبعا هناك نقاش مع حماس هل تدخل
هذا المجال هذه المعركه ام لا هنالك وعود
من حماسه الوسطاء المصريين والقطريين بان
لا تدخل هذه المعركه واسرائيل من جهه اخرى
تظهر للجميع انها مستعده لخوض معركه طويله
واسعه متعدده الجبهات ولذلك نراها في
الجنوب تفرغ البلدات من المواطنين وتتخذ
اجراء في التعليم توقف التجاره وتحذر
الناس من ان هنالك خطر بان يكون هنالك
معركه واسعه غدا او الليله الغدر ولذلك
المطروحه السيد نظير الان يعني ما اوراق
الضغط المهمه التي تمتلكها الفصائل
الفلسطينيه الاكيد بانه الرد سيكون موحدا
هكذا تم الاعلان ولكن هل نتحدث عن جبهه
فقط واحده ام جبهات متعدده ونطاق هذا الرد
المجالات متعدده كيف يمكن ان يطوروا
الموضوع ويوسعوه سؤال ما هي نتيجه اعتقد
ان هذه المساله تحتاج الى رؤيه مختلفه غير
الرؤيه التقليديه التي نراها اليوم هذه
معركه اذا كان من المفروض ان يقودها الشعب
الفلسطيني فليخضها بمشاركه جميع القوى
الفلسطينيه من دون انقسامات ومن دون
صراعات وضربات تحت الاحزمه من الاطراف
المختلفه اليوم ليس مؤهلا الشعب الفلسطيني
ان يدخل حربا وان في اسرائيل الجيش
الاسرائيلي يواجه هجوما من اليمين المتطرف
الحاكم
واوصاق واسعه منه وهو يمثل الان تلك
الحمله الاحتجاجيه الضخمه المهيبه التي
تحاول ان تدافع عن اسرائيل من اليمين
المتضرر وهو لا يريد في هذا الوقت بالذات
ان يبدو ضعيفا وهزيلا كما يدعي من قبل
الجمهور ولذلك يجب نفسه الان لا يريد حربه
وانه يعرف ان هذه الحرب ستساعد في معركته
لتمرير
الانقلابيه على انظمه الحكم واضعاف القضاء
لا يريد ان يساعد نتنياهو الجيش ولكن امام
المساس به من الداخل والمساس به من الخارج
يحاول ان يستعرض كل عضلاته الان ولذلك
يعلن كمال لو انه يدخل الحرب يعني عندما
يظهر رئيس الحكومه ووزير الدفاع ورئيس
اركان ورئيس المخابرات كلهم في مؤتمر صحفي
تتخيلين انهم يتحدثون عن حرب مع دوله
عظيمه وهو كلها حرب مع حماس او مع الجهاد
الاسلامي ولكن كل هذه الابا التي يظهرون
هي محاوله من الجيش ان يقول انه لن يحتمل
المساس بهيبته لا من الخارج من الجهاد
الاسلامي ولا من الداخل من اليمين المتطرف
في اسرائيل الان ماء خيارات او تحديات
فعليا تحديات الفصائل الفلسطينيه يعني
نتحدث عن عوده السياسه الاغتيالات من قبل
اسرائيل
نتحدث الان وكانه غزه هي الخاصره الرخوه
بالساحه وايضا عن كسر قواعد الاشتباك يعني
هناك تحديات كبرى تواجه الفصائل
نعم هي تستطيع ان توقظ هذه المعركه عن
طريق ان يعني تبلع هذه المعركه ولا تاخذها
حتى النهايه هنا
الانانيه لا تنفع في مثل هذه الحالات كل
واحد يعني ينبغي ان يقرا الخارطه جيدا
ويرى مدى قوته وامكانياته في التغلب على
هذا
الهوج الاسرائيلي التستيريا الاسرائيليه
التي تبدي استعدادا للقيام
بضربات غير عاديه على غزه وغير غزه فهذا
يحتاج الى قراءه استراتيجيه وليس الى قرار
من الجهاد الاسلامي وحده او الجهاد
الاسلامي وحماس حتى العالم ليس معهم لا
يخاطبون المجتمع الدولي لا يطرحون برنامجا
سياسيا يؤيده العالم ولذلك نجد ان
الولايات المتحده اوروبا يتحفظون من قتل
المدنيين لكنهم لا يتعرضون ابدا من قتل
قاده الجهات الاسلامي فمثل هذه المعركه
تخلق تحديات سياسيه كبيره وطبعا الشعب في
غزه يعاني معنا مره ليس سهلا ان يتقبل مره
اخرى هجوم وحرب ودمار وهذه حسابات يعني
تاخذها هذه القوه بعين الاعتبار وهم
يتحدثون مع الوسطاء وفي القاهره وفي غيرها
ويحاولون ان يتدارسوا ما الذي يمكن عمله
وهل يجوز ان ينسحبوا الى وراء قليلا خصوصا
بعدما اعلنت اعلن رئيس المخابرات
الاسرائيليه انهم اكتشفوا مصانع
الصواريخ في الجنين وكذلك مصانع للطائرات
المسيره هذا يعني ان يعني هنالك انجاز
بعيد المدى حققته ايران في هذه المنطقه
وهذا يعني ان رد الاسرائيلي والتهدير
الاسرائيلي جاد للغايه ولذلك ينبغي ان
يدرسوا بالضبط ما هو الثمن الذي ممكن ان
يكلفه مثل هذه العم هذه الهستيريه التي
وصفتها
لتصريحات القاده
الاسرائيليين يمكن ان يعني
تخيف لا لا نقول تخيف ولكن ان تعيد حسابات
فصائل الفلسطينيه ربما بالرد يبدو انه
الوقت انتهى السيد نظير مجلي اشكرك على
ارائك معنا الليله حدثا من الناصره
وفي الدفع الغربيه اصيب ثلاثه عشره
فلسطينيا برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي كما اصيب
العشرات بحالات اختناق بالغاز المسيل
للدموع خلال مواجهات واشتباكات مسلحه بين
الفلسطينيين والجيش الاسرائيلي الذي اقتحم
البلده القديمه من مدينه نابلس واعتقل
فلسطينيين اثنين
[موسيقى]
بنفس الاسلوب قوات خاصه اسرائيليه تدخل
البلده القديمه من نابلس تتبعها عشرات
الاليات العسكريه القوات الخاصه حاصرت
منزلا في حاره القريون والاليات الثقيله
حاصرت البلده القديمه من نابلس وهو مباشره
اتجهنا نحو حمزه وغم وربط وممكن نوعا ما
اخدعونا لتحقيق عزله بغرفه بغرفه معينه
تقريبا اعدوا تقريبا ساعه
ولبين ما يقول لي انهن خرجوا وانسحبوا من
المنطقه
اشتباكات مسلحه رافقت اقتحام الجيش
الاسرائيلي لنابلس اسفرت عن اصابه جندي
اسرائيلي
وثلاثه عشر فلسطينيا بالرصاص وسبعين
بالاختناق جراء استنشاق الغاز المسيله
للدموع اضافه الى اعتقال فلسطينيين تقول
اسرائيل انهما هدف العمليه رغم ان العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه اليوم في نابلس لم
توقع ضحايا الا انها تعيد التاكيد ان
الفعل ورده الفعل تبقي دوامه العنف دائره
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه من حاره القريون في
البلده القديمه بنابلس خالد القاسم
العربيه
[موسيقى]
تتابعون بعض الفاصله
احتفال مختلف في روسيا بذكرى النصر على
النازيه وبوتين يرهن مستقبل روسيا بعمل
جنودها باوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وصلت الى مطار بورسودان
الطائره الاغاثيه الاولى ضمن الجسر الجوي
السعودي الاغاثي وتحمل على متنها
المساعدات الاغاثيه التي تشتمل على السلال
الغذائيه والمواد الايوائيه والطبيه وتزن
عشره اطنان واوضح مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه ان المساعدات الانسانيه المقدمه
من المملكه للشعب السوداني تاتي للتخفيف
من معاناه المتضررين وهي امتداد لدعم
المملكه للسودان في شتى القطاعات
الانسانيه
الى ذلك اكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي خلال
مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره البريطاني
ان واشنطن لن تتخلى عن هدفي اعاده السودان
الى الحكم المدني الديمقراطي مشيرا الى ان
الاداره الامريكيه تعمل مع السعوديه
لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار في السودان وكذلك
التوصل الى اتفاق لايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه وتامينها الى السودانيين
منذ الرابع عشر من ابريل الماضي وعشرات
الالاف من السودانيين بين نزوح داخل
البلاد او الوجود لدول الجوار بحسب بيانات
امميه حيث انه المفوضيه العليا لشؤون
اللاجئين كشفت عن ان اكثر من 700 الف شخص
فرو من ديارهم في السودان بسبب القتال بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع واضافت المنظمه
الدوليه ان عدد النازحين داخل السودان بلغ
نحو
340 الفا بحسب البيانات بينما كان ما لا
يقل عن 150 الف شخص عبروا بالفعل الحدود
السودانيه الى دول الجوار هذه الارقام
تزيد العبء على السودان الذي كان لديه
ثلاثه ملايين و700,000 نازح اصلا قبل
اندلاع القتال الحالي وايضا اكثر من مليون
لاجئ من الدول المجاوره اليوم اعلنت
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين عن احصاء مذهله
لاعداد اللاجئين المتوقعه حصه الاسد ستكون
لمصر مع 300 وخمسين الفا من السودان حسب
التوقعات لها جنوب السودان ب 240 الف لاجئ
وصل اليها بالفعل اكثر من 35 الف لاجئ
ايضا توقعت مفوضيه اللاجئين ان يصل عشرات
الالاف الى دول جوار اخرى مثل تشاد وليبيا
واثيوبيا واريتريا وجمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى طبعا تسعى المفوضيه العليا لشؤون
اللاجئين للحصول على
445 مليون دولار اضافيه للعمل والتعامل مع
الهجره الجماعيه المتوقعه لدول الجوار
السوداني
عدد النازحين داخليا في السودان ارتفع الى
اكثر من الضعف في الاسبوع الماضي حسب
بيانات تتبع النزوح في المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره وهناك الان اكثر من 700 الف نازح
داخليا بسبب القتال الذي بدا في الخامس
عشر من ابريل وفقا لبياناتنا
ودت المعارك الدائره بين الجيش والدعم
السريع الى ركود في الاسواق التجاريه في
ولايه جنوب دارفور غرب السودان وتعد هذه
الولايه هي المغذي الرئيسي لعدد من
المناطق باقليم دارفور والدول المجاوره
في اسواقهم ترى جمالياتهم وبراءتهم
وطيبتهم هنا في نيالا جنوب دارفور غربيه
السودان الاثار الاقتصاديه للاقتتال بين
الجيش والدعم السريع خلفت ركودا كبيرا لم
يتوقعه المنتجون منذ سنوات بعيده والله
حركه البيع يعني ما زي زمان الناس كلها
شاده يعني الناس امام ما في الحرب
الحرب شتت الناس كلها
المواصلات بقت بالف جنيه والمواصلات صعبه
في البيت انت ترقد تكون متقلقل تسمع صوت
السلاح 24 ساعه والذخيره وتعدني على ثاني
اكبر المدن في السودان المركز التجاري
الاضخم باقليم دارفور ونافذه عالميه للدول
المجاوره للبلاد
تهشم الامر فيها وادى الى توقف الحركه
التجاريه
باسواق الولايه اسعار زمان الشوال بتاعه
باميه بعشرين الف هسه بقت بعشره 12 ب 11
والطماطم كان بعشرين خمسه وعشرين هسه رجع
الى 15 18 17
واي خبر نزل حبوب شديد يعني هذا السوق كان
يعج بالحركه اصبح اليوم شبه خالي اذ لا
يمكن لاحد ان يوقظه من نومه وسط اصوات
الرصاص التي تسمع كل يوم والله خساره
كبيره ما بيتحمل يعني يوم واحد ما بيتحمل
لكن طبعا الحرده امتدت هسه قال لنا 22 يوم
بالنسبه للحرب ده والناس طلعت يعني طلعت
من من في يدين ومن اي شيء وطلعت من اموال
ومن انفسهم يعني خايفين بالنسبه لنفسهم
يعني في بلد تجر
ى عمر نواه
عادي غياب الامن يعيده الى ايام توصف
بالمؤلمه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه استئناف عملي
بعثتها الدبلوماسيه في الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه وذلك حرصا في الاسهام على تطوير
العمل العربي المشتركي وتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه وكذلك تنفيذا لقرار
الجامعه العربيه الاخيره بشان عوده سوريا
لانشطه واجتماعات الهيئات والمنظمات
التابعه لها
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه التركيه انا الوزير
مولود شاويش اوغلو سيلتقي وزراء خارجيه
سوريا وروسيا وايران في موسكو وقلت
الخارجيه التركيه ان اللقاء الذي سينعقد
في موسكو سيناقش تطبيع العلاقات بين تركيا
وسوريا الى جانب العمليه السياسيه واعاده
اللاجئين الى بلادهم بشكل امن
[موسيقى]
انفجرت اعمال شغب واشتباكات في كراتشي
بباكستان بعد اعتقال الشرطه الباكستانيه
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان على ذمه
تحقيق في قضيه فساد بعد حكم من المحكمه
العليا باسم اباده والقضيه المتهم فيها
خان بالكسب غير المشروع هي واحده من اكثر
من 100 قضيه مرفوعه ضده منذ ان اطاح به
تصويت برلماني من السلطه في ابريل نيسان
من العام الماضي واثارت محاولات اعتقال
عمران خان في وقت سابق احتجاجات واشتباكات
بين الشرطه وانصاره لكنه ينفي كافه
الاتهامات ضده بالفساد ويعتبروا القضايا
مسيسه وواهيه
[موسيقى]
هذا وقت حمام ناصر رئيس الوزراء
الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان مقر
الاستخبارات الباكستانيه في مدينه فيصل
اباده وافاد مراسل العربيه انا مدنا
رئيسيه باكستانيه تشهد اعمال شغب لانصار
حزب عمران خانق واكد ان مناصري عمران خان
اقتحموا ايضا مقرين عسكريين في منطقتين
شمال شرق باكستان
وقال رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان في مقطع مسجل قبل اعتقاله انه
مستعد للذهاب الى السجن بمقضي ادارته او
ارادته مؤكدا انه ليس مدان باي قضيه
تستدعي القاء القبض عليه
اذا كان لدى شخص ما اوامر بالقاء القبض
عليه فاحضروا لي مذكره توقيف سيكون محامي
الخاص بانتظاري انا مستعد للذهاب الى
السجن بنفسي صنعوا مشهد مثير سيهدر
الموارد كما لو كان اكبر مجرم في البلاد
قادما قدموا اوامر مباشره لاعتقالي بالرغم
من عدم وجود اي قضيه ضدي الا انني مستعد
نفسيا للسجن
وانضم الينا من اسلام اباد جويه حفيظ
السفير السابق اهلا بك سيد حفيظ يعني
برايك الى اين تتجه الامور الان ان كان بي
اسلام اباد او حتى بكراتشي وهل سيستطيع
منى
عمران خان قلب الطاوله ربما والضغط لاخراج
من السجن
هل تسمعني سيد حفيظ
لا لم يكن الصوت
الى اين تتجه الامور الان ان كان باسلام
اباد وايضا بكراتشي ولاهور بعد اعتقال
عمران خان هل سيستطيع مناصره الضغط لاخراج
من السجن
الامور تزداد سوءا كما راينا اليوم على
الشغب
والاحتجاج في اكثر المدن
الباكستانيه لسكان موسونال وكراشي ومشاور
وخرجوا وخرج المناصر
هو اكثر الاساس شعبيه في باكستان
وتم تفاله اليوم
في مبنى المحكمه العليا في اسلام اباد
والاعتقال داخل المبنى في المحكمه هذا
ايضا شيء غير مسبوق في باكستان
هناك غليان هناك
غضب شعبي في باكستان بهذه المجال يعني نعم
السيد حفيظ يعني ملفات قضايا الفساد سبق
ان فتحت
بحكومه عمران خان وتم سجن عده قاده لاحزاب
بوقتها لماذا لا يقبل ذلك على نفسه الان
وحتى مناصري لان هناك حديث عن انتقادات
وانتقائيه ويعني معامله تفضيليه يحظى بها
عمران خان اصلا لانه العديد من مذكرات
التوقيف استطاع ان يفلت منها
هناك يعني هناك اتهامات يعني
في باكستان كما يقال الفيلم وحتى الان لم
تتم ادعمته فهو كمان كما قلت الشعب
الباكستاني هو يفتكر بانه
عمران خان هو
ليس فاسدا بل الحكومه الحاليه
والاحزاب الحاكمه الان هيا اقصر فسادا من
امران القلب وهذا اصلا الصراع على سلطه
وكل هذه
الاتهامات والقضايا ضد
عمران هذا جزء من الصراع على على
وطبعا هذه الصراعة قد اصبح
شديد جدا
وهذا يزداد والعودات
وقد يؤثر
التي هشه الان
الاقتصاد ضعيف جدا وعدم استقرار
شكرا جزيلا لك من اسلام اباد جويد حفيظ
سفير سابق شكرا على رايك
[موسيقى]
اتمنى الجمعيه الوطنيه الفرنسيه بالاجماع
اقتراح اصدار قرار بموجبه يتم تصنيف
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه وادراجها على قائمه
المنظمات الارهابيه جاء ذلك بموافقه جميع
الاعضاء الحاضرين للجلسه وعددهم 331 حيث
لم يرفض القرار اي عضو وايد الاتحاد
الاوروبي فرنسا في دعوتها لادراج فاجنر
على قائمه المنظمه الارهابيه
في هجوم هو الاعنف اتهمه قائد قوات
فاجنريفيني القاده العسكريين بروسيا
بالغباء في قياده المعارك في اوكرانيا
واشار الى عدم قدره الدوله الروسيه على
الدفاع عن البلاد كاشفا عن خداع يتعرض له
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين فيما يخص حرب
اوكرانيا
كان هذا اليوم الموعود للاستيلاء على
باقمه الاوكرانيه رمزيه النصر في يوم
النصر وفقا لقائد قوات فاجنر والقياده
الروسيه ايضا لكنه تحول الى اعنف هجوم
يشنه
على قيادات الكريمه
لا يجب ان يموت الجندي بسبب الغباء المطلق
للقياده في موسكو الجنرالات والضباط على
الارض ملزمون بتنفيذ هذا الغباء لان
الاوامر التي تصلهم من الاعلى هي اجراميه
بكل ما تحمله الكلمه من معنى غباء القياده
هذا ليس الاحتراف الوحيد الذي كشفه زعيم
قوات باجنر فالرجل رفع من سقف حربه مع
رجال الكرملين حد التشكيك بقدره الحكومه
الروسيه في الدفاع عن البلاد
اوكرانيا تضرب المناطق الحدوديه الروسيه
بنجاح لماذا الدوله الروسيه غير قادره على
الدفاع عن البلاد
كانوا مشغولين بنصب المكائد بدلا من
القتال يقول بريكوجين امر انعكس على جبهات
القتال ودفعت جنود الروس الى الفرار من
ساحات المعارك جبن مبطن للجيش تهمهم به
طبخ بوتينغ كما كان يطلق عليه فوفقا للرجل
فان وحده عسكريه روسيه فرت مؤخرا من
مواقعها قرب باخموت ما جعلت جبهه مكشوفه
على خطوط القتال التي تتمركز فيه قواته
كما لم تتلقى مجموعته سوى عشره بالمئه من
الذخيره اللازمه للقتال امر اعتبره الرجل
جريمه لتدمير الشعب الروسي ايام وتنسحب
فاجنر من تخوم باخموت يقول افيني فحتى
بوتين مخدوع من قبل جنرالته في الحمله
العسكريه في اوكرانيا خداع قال انهم
سيدفعون ثمنه على يد القائد او الشعب
الروسي اذا خسر الحرب رائد المصطفى
العربيه
ومن العاصمه الدنماركيه
المتخصص في الشان الروسي سامر الياس اهلا
بك معنا سيد سامر يعني كيف تفسر الصمت
الروسي وتحديدا صمت الكريم حتى الان عن
هذه التصريحات الناريه والاتهامات بالغباء
التي يواجهها
للقاده العسكريين هل نتحدث عن يعني تصفيه
حسابات ومنافسه وصراع نفوذ مع وزير الدفاع
فقط ام عن تبرير لعدم يعني حصوله وحصوله
على بخموت وسيطرته عليها حتى الان
نعم مساء الخير هناك تنافس كبير بين
فاجنر وبين قيادات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
هذا بدا واضح منذ اشهر طويله هناك ايضا
تنافس بين الطرفين من اجل كسب قلب سيد
الكرملين الرئيس بلادي مربوطن والتقرب منه
بشكل اكبر اليوم في احتفالات ذكر كان هناك
على المنصه عدد من الجنود الذين حاربوا
ضمن قوات باجنر اضافه الى
العسكريين القدماء واضافه الى عدد من
اركان وزاره الدفاع ايضا لا يمكن استبعاد
ان فاجنر ورئيسهم في هجومه الشديد اليوم
في فيديو طويل جدا كان لافت بانه انتقد
بشكل حاد الجانب
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وحملها المسؤوليه عن
عدم التقدم في مخبوط هو يريد رفع
المسؤوليه عن ذاته عندما قال بانه لم
يتلقى السلاح الكافي اليوم عندما اشار الى
انسحاب مجموعه من الجيش الروسي من ضاق
متقال بان هذه المنطقه التي انسحب منها
وهذا القطاع الذي انسحب منه الجنود من
الجيش الروسي دفعنا ثمنه 500 قتيل من جنود
فاينر هو يريد تبرير بانه لم يستطع الحصول
انجاز في باقي بسبب غباء وزاره الدفاع
بسبب عدم قيامها بالشيء اللازم
المؤكد بان الحديث الذي يتحدث فيه لو كان
تحدث به اي صحفي او اي انسان في روسيا كان
سجن لمده
داخلي يعاقب من ينتقد هذه العمليه
العسكريه ولكن مؤسس فاجن قال ايضا بانه
حصل فقط على عشره او 15% من الذخيره
المطلوب التي طلبها وهو يكرر ايضا هذه
الاتهامات بانه لا يحصل على ماذا ما يريده
لماذا لا يتم تزويده بالذخيره التي
يحتاجها للحصول على بخمه
ربما يريد هو ربما حصل على ذخيره اكثر
ويريد تبرير عجزه ولكن ايضا وزاره الدفاع
جنرالات وزاره الدفاع يريدون نسب النصر
اليهم في نهايه العام الماضي تم تحرير
قريه تدعس الادار على يد قوات فاجنر بشكل
اساسي وبوجود وزاره الدفاع البيان الاول
لوزاره الدفاع اشار الى ان الجيش الروسي
قام بتحرير هذه القريه ولكن في المساء
وبعد اعتراضات كبيره لان بريجوجن له ايضا
مجموعه داعمه له في داخل الكرملين له
مجموعه داعمه من القوميين وله وسائل
الاعلام فاعله في روسيا ومراسلين عسكريين
في المساء اضطرت وزاره الدفاع الى القول
بان هذا النصر تم بمشاركه فاعله من قبل
قوات فاجنر ارى بانه اليوم هناك تحالفات
ضد جنرالات وزاره الدفاع بالتعاون مع
قديره على سبيل المثال حاكم الشيشان الذي
ايضا لم يكن له دور فعال كبير
بالاشاره له نعم الرئيس الروسي قال بخطاب
النصر اليوم بانه روسيا تواجه حربا حقيقيه
وشامله لماذا اذا لا يتم اعلان الحرب من
الجانب الروسي والاكتفاء بتسميه ما يحصل
بعمليه عسكريه
نعم ممتاز الجانب الروسي يحرص منذ بدايه
الحرب على اوكرانيا بتسميتها عمليه عسكريه
خاصه حتى لا يعلن بانها حرب ولا يقول بان
هناك تحدي كبير وخطر وجودي على روسيا في
الداخل الروسي حتى لا يغضب المواطنين
الروس ويخيفهم من ان روسيا بعظمتها وكبرى
17 مليون كيلو متر مربع مقابل 600 كيلو
متر مربع لا تستطيع السيطره على مناطق
واسعه من اوكرانيا رغم 15 عاما من الحرب
اعلان الحرب يقضي بانه هناك بعض مخاوف من
قبل الروس وجدنا عند اعلان التعبئه
الجزئيه في شهر سبتمبر ايلول الماضي فرار
اكثر من 500 الف شاب روسي الى خارج روسيا
الى كازاخستان وجورجيا وغيرها من الدول
المرافق لها وحتى الى الامارات العربيه
المتحده وتركيا ومصر هذه الطوابير لا يريد
بوتين ان تتكرر بخروج المواطنين الروس الى
الخارج ولا يريد الظهور بمظهر
[موسيقى]
وننتقل لنتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور
المباشره من نيويورك حيث حملت هيئه
المحلفين في محكمه في المدينه الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب المسؤوليه
عن اعتداء جنسي على كاتبه واصحه في
السابقه في تسعينيات القرن الماضي بحسب ما
افادت به وسائل الاعلام امريكيه كما قررت
تغريم ترامب خمسه ملايين دولار في القضيه
فطبعا التشهير بها
طبعا
نتابع هذه الصور المباشره اذا من نيويورك
بالعوده الى روسيا احتفلت موسكو بالذكرى
الثامنه والسبعين للنصري على النازيه
وصفات نيويورك تايمز بيوم النصر الصامت
بسبب الغاء الاستعراض الجوي لاسباب امنيه
وحضر الاستعراض الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
الذي حيى جنوده في خطاب حماسي وشدد على ان
مستقبل روسيا يعتمد على جنودها في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وفي الوقت الذي تحتفل موسكو بالتاسع من
مايو بعيد النصر يغيب الاحتفال الرسمي في
كييف الذي الغي بسبب الحرب اما شعبيا
فقليل ممن عاصر حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي
اوقاتل في صفوفه ما زال يحيي الذكرى
بزياره النصب التذكاريه للجنود المجهول
بينما تحتفل فيه موسكو بعيد النصر
الغتكييف احتفالات التاسع من مايو بسبب
الحرب الروسيه يوم اعتاد اوكرانيون احيائه
لعقود سابقه لكن الحرب غير ذلك
فالاحتفالات ولا عرض عسكري الى هنا حيث
النصب التذكاري والشعله التي لا تنطفئ
تعود الاوكرانيون ان ياتوا لاحياء ذكرى
الجنود المجهولين الذين قتلوا او قضوا في
الحرب على النازيه
جدايل اثنين قاتله في الحرب العالميه وابي
كان احد قاده المقاومه احد جديه توفي في
الحرب والاخر عاد حيا اخبروني كثيرا عن
ذلك هذه عائلتنا ونحن يجب ان نتذكر ذلك
والدي كان من جنود البحريه وقاتل وعاد حيا
من الحرب وكان يحترم هذا اليوم ويحتفل به
ونحن احببنا هذا اليوم ونتذكره دائما ومع
تواصل الحرب تتراجع الاحتفالات وي الحضور
الا من بعض من ذوي الضباط والجنود الذين
حاربوا النازيه في صفوف جيش الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق هؤلاء يرفضون تغيير تاريخ
ذكرى الحرب من التاسعه الى الثامنه من
مايو بحسب مشروع قانون رئيس الذي قدمه
للبرلمان
احتفل بيوم النصر في التاسع من مايو رفقه
الحاضرين هنا يوم حرب اوروبا وتحريرها من
النازيه اما الثامن من مايو الذي يريد
رئيس نازيسكا ان يحتفل به فليحتفل به
لوحده كان شارع الخرشات وسط كييف يشهد
عرضا عسكريا في هذا اليوم الامر الذي يغيب
منذ اندلاع الحرب وكانت الذكرى يوما يحتفل
فيه جميع ابناء الشعب الاوكراني حتى داخل
بيوتهم الا ان الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
انتزعته من نفوس الكثيرين ولم يتبقى الا
استصدار قانون تغيير تاريخ الذكرى عبر
البرلمان لتصبح الذكرى ذكريات عادل
العربيه كيف
حزمه جديده من العقوبات الاوروبيه على
روسيا من المقرر ان يعلن عنها الاتحاد
قريبا وتستهدف في جانب كبير منها شركات
صينيه دبلوماسيون قالوا انه تم تحديد
ثماني شركات صينيه يعتقد انها قدمت لموسكو
اجهزه الكترونيه بما في ذلك اشبه الموصلات
ويمكن استخدامها لاغراض عسكريه احدى تلك
الشركات هي كينج باي التي سبق ان اتهمتها
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه بتوفير الرقائق
الكترونيه دقيقه لروسيا تمكنها من
استغلالها في انظمه توجيه صواريخ كروز ليس
فقط الصواريخ شركه اخرى هي ايجا
باسيفلينكس المسجله في هونغ كونغ تحدث
التقرير بريطاني عن انها مازالت منتجاتها
تدخل في تصنيع مسيارات اورلان 10 الروسيه
ايضا من بين الشركات الصينيه من يرسل
منتجاته مباشره الى موسكو او يشتري منتجات
غربيه كوسيط ثم هذه المنتجات مزدوجه
لاستخدام الى روسيا وفي محاوله اوروبيه
لسد الثغرات تقترح حزمه العقوبات وضع نظام
لحظر تصدير بعض المنتجات الى دول خارج
الاتحاد الاوروبي او شركات يعتقد انها
تساعد روسيا في التحايل على القيود
الغربيه الانباء عن نيه فرد بروكسيل
لعقوبات على بكين دفع كبار المسؤولين
الصينيين الى التلويح بالرد بقوه على
العقوبات الاوروبيه التحذير جاء من وزير
الخارجي الصيني في برلين خلال لقائه مع
نظيرته الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
نحن لا نزود البلدان التي تمر بازمات
باسلحه هذا قانوننا في الصين وعندما نصدر
منتجات باستخدام مزدوج لدينا ايضا قوانين
لتنظيم تلك الحالات هناك تعاون بين شركات
الصين وروسيا ولا يجب زعزعه هذا التبادل
الطبيعي نعارض بشده قيام بعض الدول وفق
قوانينها المحليه بفرض عقوبات احاديه
الجانب ضد الصين او اي دوله اخرى واذا كان
الامر كذلك فسنرد ايضا بشكل صارم وحاد
وسندافع عن المصالح القانونيه والمشروعه
لبلدنا وشركاتنا
[موسيقى]
للاوروبيين لا تخشوا من استعراض بوتين
لقواته تابعونا بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اندلع حريق كبير في محطه
عباس سبور للطاقه بمدينه اصفهان الايرانيه
وذكر شهود عيان ان بلديه اصفهان ارسلت
عربات اطفاء الى الموقع لاخماد الحريق
وذكرت تقارير ان الحريق اندلع بعد ملاحظه
مسيرات تحلق في محيطه في اشاره الى انها
هجوم اسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
الانتخابات التركيه للعام 2023 تعد فاصله
في الحياه السياسيه التركيه والمسار الذي
ستتخذه البلاد في حال فوز او خساره
اردوغان المزيد من التفاصيل مع روان حمزه
[موسيقى]
الانتخابات التركيه في 2023 انتخابات
مختلفه سياسيا واقتصاديا واجتماعيا هي
المره الاولى التي واجهوا فيها اردوغان
تحالفا يضم سته احزاب معارضه بينها حزباني
كبيران كما انها ليست منافسه تقليديه بين
ائتلافين حاكم ومعارض بقدر ما هي صراع على
تحديد هويه تركيا في قرنها الثاني ومفترق
طريق ستسلكه البلاد باردوغان او بدونه
سواء كانت الانتخابات الرئاسيه او
البرلمانيه الثامنه والعشرين تحظى باهميه
واحده حيث تاتي بعد مرور 100 عام على
تاسيس الجمهوريه التركيه
الطريق الذي ستنتهي به هذه الانتخابات في
حال فاز فيها اردوغان هو طريق قرن جديد
بوعود كبيره من قبل الرئيس التركي وفرصه
لتثبيت مشروعه السياسي اما خساره اردوغان
للرئاسه فقد تعني حقبه جديده داخليا
دستورا واصلاحات جديده وهو ما تساله
المعارضه من خلال الاطاحه باردوغان بهدف
دخول حقبه جديده تبدا بالتراجع عن سياساته
داخليا اي منعطف تسلكه الانتخابات قد يعني
تغيرات توجهات تركيا الخارجيه خاصه ان
الدوره والتاثير التركيه في الشؤون
الدوليه يمثل تحديا للمعارضه فهو شهاده
على انجازات اردوغان عقدان كانت الفتره
الاخيره الاصعب فيهما فقد شهدت فيها تركيا
متغيرات عده اقتصاديه على راسها التضخم
وكذلك كوارث طبيعيه زلزال كان بمثابه
اختبار للرئيس التركي لذا فان ما ستقرره
صناديق الاقتراع لن يتعلق فقط بمن سيحكم
لكن بكيفيه الحكم والمسار الاقتصادي الذي
سيسلكه الفائز وسياساته داخليا او خارجيا
تحرك جديد اطلقه المودعون بوجه جمعيات
المصارف مهددين بالتصعيد في ظل التفكك
الدوله وتكبير القضاء ومع استمرار
الاستجوابات القضائيه الاوروبيه لحاكم
مصرف لبنان
ومتورتين معه بتهم تحويل اموال الى الخارج
يحاول الداخل عرقله عمل القضاء المتهمه
اصلا بالكيل بمكيالين اكد المذيعون ان
تحركاتهم لن تتوقف قبل استعاده اموالهم
التي هرب قسم منها للخارج
هذا تحرك من مئات التحركات التي شنتها
جمعيه صرخه المودعين منذ بدء الازمه ولا
اجابه حتى الان حول السؤال اين تبخرت
الودائع تحرك اليوم موجه ضد الافرع
الرئيسيه للمصارف التي يتهمها المودرون
بالتواطئ مع السلطه ما ادى الى خساره
ودائعهم
المصارف هنا اقفلت ابوابها تحسبا لتظاهرات
قد لا تخلو من العنف لكن التحرك حافظ على
سميته مع اللجوء الى المفرقعات حينما ورفع
الشعارات على حواجز المصارف الحديديه
احيانا
نحن حقنا وتعبنا وعمرنا بالغربه ما حنتركه
لا ياخذوا نصه ولا يخدوا ربعه
والله العظيم مش قادرين نشتري شيء
لاولادنا معقول بيعطونا 30 مليون
دولار شهريت المذي
هذه التحركات تاتي بعد اسبوع قضائي حافل
وفود قضائيه اوروبيه استمعت الى وزير
المال وشقيق حاكم مصرف لبنان بتهن تسهيل
تحويل اموال على حساب حقوق الموضعين
المنهوبين اما محليا فكان الاتجاه معاكسا
طردت القاضيه اخذ عون التي كان لها جولات
في كشف قضايا فساد متعلقه بتحويل الاموال
ايش الموضوع فقط عند القضاء الموضوع هو
بمنظومه مقفله على ذاتها مترابطه الحلقات
ولا تسمح لنفسها بان تهوى هذا هو المكان
يلي اليوم نحن عنا السلطه متمسكه بكل
تاريخ السابع يلي هو تاريخ لا يستقيم الا
بالعداله وبالتاكيد باعطاء الحقوق
سوى التحرك سهامه اليوم على رئيس حكومه
تصنيف الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي احد اسرى
اثرياء العرب والمتهم بالاستفاده من قروض
الاسكان المخصصه لذوي الدخل المحدود غنوه
العربيه بيروت
[موسيقى]
تصريح اليوم هو للمستشار الالماني او
لاشولز الذي قال ان استعراض الرئيس الروسي
لقوته في ساحه الحمراء بموسكو يجب ان لا
يؤدي الى ترهيب الاتحاد الاوروبي اكد امام
البرلمان الاوروبي ضروره ان تبقى اوروبا
حازمه في دعمها لاوكرانيا
يوما ما كانت هذه البقعه من اسبانيا مليئه
بالمياه اما الان فقد اصبحت ارضا قاحله
نتيجه موجه جفاف الاسوا في البلاد منذ
خمسه عقود رفقها ارتفاع قياسي بدرجه
الحراره سجله شهر ابريل الموصلي وفيما بات
الجفاف يهدد بموسم كارثي لمزارع اسبانيا
وجد بعضهم في جنوب البلاد طرقا غير
قانونيه لري محاصيلهم من الافوكادو تلك
الفاكهه الاستوائيه التي تحتاج الى كميه
كبيره من المياه الشرطه القتل اليوم القبض
على 26 شخصا بسبب حفل ابر غير قانونيه كما
نشاهد في الصور
[موسيقى]
كره اليوم من تركيا في الماضي كانت هناك
حياه بجميع تفاصيلها في الماضي كانت هناك
ذكريات واحلام اما اليوم فرحل الجميع وبقي
الركام مدينه انطاكيا التركيه بعد ثلاثه
اشهر من الزلزال المدمر لا تزال تعيش
الكابوسه مع مئات الالاف من الاطماني
من الانقاد
نكتفي بهذا القدر من الاخبار والملفات لكن
الزميل صهيب شرايري يفتح المزيد من
الملفات واخبار الساعه مساء الخير يا صهيب
مساء الخير يا راويه اهلا بك مره اخرى
طبعا اخبار الساعه كالعاده جوله سريعه
شامله ومتنوعه من الاخبار اليوم في
الصداره طبعا التصعيد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واستئناف عمل البعثه
الدبلوماسيه السعوديه في سوريا لدينا
نافذه على الانتخابات التركيه مع الزميل
طاهر بعد قليل سيكون معنا في اخبار الساعه
ليس في 360 اليوم معك اتخلى عني شكرا شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات